THREE SECONDS BACK, I’LL GIVE IT
TO YOU.
GREAT JOB AS ALWAYS.
BUSY NIGHT TONIGHT ON "HANNITY,"
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
THE PRESIDENT TONIGHT TAKING
BOLD ACTION TO SECURE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, IT’S SAD WHEN
YOU STOP AND THINK, THIS IS
ABOUT LIVES, OUR FELLOW
AMERICANS, SERIOUSNESS INVOLVED
IN THIS, YOU WOULDN’T KNOW THE
MEDIA, DEMOCRATS, THE ONE GUY
WHO WAS HEAD OF THE CURVE AS IT
RELATES TO CHINA, TRAVEL BANDS,
THE NEED TO SECURE AMERICA’S
BORDERS IS NOW TAKING ANOTHER
IMPORTANT MEASURE TO PROTECT
THE, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND OUR
JOBS, TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE HAVE A SOLEMN DUTY TO
ENSURE THESE UNEMPLOYED
AMERICANS REGAIN THEIR JOBS AND
LIVELIHOODS, IN ORDER TO PROTECT
AMERICAN WORKERS.
I WILL BE ISSUING A TEMPORARY
SUSPENSION OF IMMIGRATION INTO
THE UNITED STATES, YOU HEARD
ABOUT THAT LAST NIGHT.
BY PAUSING IMMIGRATION IT WILL
HELP PUT UNEMPLOYED AMERICANS
FIRST IN LINE AS AMERICA
REOPENS.
SO IMPORTANT, IT WOULD BE WRONG
AND UNJUST FOR AMERICANS LAID
OFF BY THE VIRUS TO BE REPLACED
WITH NEW IMMIGRANT LABOR FLOWN
IN FROM ABROAD.
>> Sean: ESSENTIAL WORKERS
WILL BE EXEMPT FROM IMMIGRATION
SUSPENSION, THAT WOULD INCLUDE
DOCTORS BATTLING COVID-19, OTHER
HEALTH WORKERS AND AMERICANS WE
ALWAYS WELCOME IMMIGRANTS.
THE PRESIDENT’S RIGHT TO SECURE
OUR BORDERS, WHY?
WE NEED TO BET PEOPLE AND MAKE
SURE THEY DON’T HAVE RADICAL
TIES.
PEOPLE ARE HEALTHY, MAKE SURE
THEY ARE HEALTHY TO PROTECT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THEY HAVE TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
FOR THEMSELVES AND 90% OF
AMERICA’S HEROIN ACROSS IS THAT
BORDER.
THE 60 DAY SUSPENSION WILL GIVE
US TIME TO ASSESS OUR ECONOMY
AND GIVE AMERICANS TIME TO GET
BACK TO WORK, WHAT WE HAVE NOW
WITNESSED IN THE PAST SEVERAL
MONTHS, THE MEDIA MOB WILL NEVER
TELL YOU, DEMOCRATS WILL NEVER
ACKNOWLEDGE IT, IT IS
UNPRECEDENTED AND DO SO IS THIS
ADMINISTRATION RESPONSE.
WE ARE NOW WITNESSING RIGHT
BEFORE OUR VERY EYES WHAT IS THE
GREATEST MEDICAL MOBILIZATION IS
THIS COUNTRY HAS EVER SEEN.
PRESIDENT TRUMP VOWS TO GIVE
STATES ALL THE CRITICAL
SUPPLIES, THE RESORTS THEY NEED
TO COME UP MOST STATES, MOST
GOVERNORS WERE NOT PREPARED FOR
ANYTHING, NO EMERGENCY.
HE IS DELIVERED ON THE PROMISE
IN A BIG WAY AND SO FAR THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
DISTRIBUTED 57.4 MILLION N95
MASKS, 12.3 MILLION SURGICAL
GOWNS, NEARLY 11,000
RESPIRATORS, THE STRATEGIC
STOCKPILE STILL HAS NEARLY
10,000 VENTILATORS, THAT NUMBER
IS SURGING.
THE GM ASSEMBLY LINE IS NOW
WORKING AND THEY ARE PRODUCING
EVERY DAY.
OVER THE NEXT WEEK, 500 WILL BE
DELIVERED AS PROMISED, WE HAVE
THOUSANDS MORE THAN WE EVER
NEEDED, TENS OF THOUSANDS MORE
WILL SOON BE ON THE WAY.
THE PRESIDENT AND HIS TEAM
TRIGGERING THE DEFENSE
PRODUCTION ACT WORKED AND THANKS
TO ALL OF THESE GREAT AMERICAN
BUSINESSES -- THEY NEVER STOPPED
WORKING.
THEY KEPT SUPPLYING OUR
HOSPITALS, OUR HEROES ON THE
FRONT LINE, OUR DOCTORS, OUR
NURSES, OUR JANITORS, THE REAL
HEROES HERE.
THEY WERE BEING SUPPORTED BY
PEOPLE WHO DIDN’T STOP WORKING,
JUST LIKE THE FOOD WAS GOING ON
THE SHELVES AND THE MEDICINE
EVEN IN STATES LIKE NEW YORK.
THEY ALL STEPPED UP, THEY NEVER
STOPPED WORKING, THEY NEVER SHUT
DOWN.
THE FARMERS FARMED, THE PACKERS
PACKED, THE TRUCKERS TRUCK.
THEY STAYED STOCKED.
MEANWHILE, THE UNITED STATES
ALSO LEADING THE WORLD IN
TESTING, NO COUNTRY CLOSE.
WE HAVE TESTED MORE OF OUR
CITIZENS IN ANY OTHER COUNTRY,
OTHER COUNTRIES COMBINED.
THE PRESIDENT MOBILIZED OUR
GREAT MILITARY, 5,500 U.S.
MILITARY PERSONNEL HAVE BEEN
DEPLOYED ACROSS TWO DOESN’T
HOSPITALS, 28,700 NATIONAL
GUARDS.
THE JAVITS CENTER, THAT
PERSONNEL CAME FROM THE
PRESIDENT.
LET’S NOT FORGET ABOUT PROJECT
AIR BRIDGE, THAT’S THE PUBLIC-
PUBLIC-PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP
ORGANIZED BY THE WHITE HOUSE
THAT SENT MASSIVE CARGO PLANES
TO PICK UP CRUCIAL MEDICAL
SUPPLIES FROM FACTORIES AROUND
THE WORLD TO GET THEM HERE AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE.
THIS MASSIVE MOBILIZATION DID
NOT HAPPEN OVERNIGHT, IT DIDN’T
HAPPEN BY CHANCE EITHER.
FROM THE VERY FIRST DAYS OF THE
VIRUS, THE PRESIDENT HAS TAKEN
ONE BOLD ACTION AFTER ANOTHER TO
PROTECT AMERICAN LIVES, THERE’S
AN OP-ED IN
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" THAT
RIGHTLY POINTED OUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP ACTED WITH
DISPATCH TO KEEP AMERICANS SAFE
EVEN WHEN IT WAS UNPOPULAR, LIKE
ON JANUARY 31ST 1
PRESIDENT TRUMP BAND TO TRAVEL
TO AND FROM CHINA, THE FIRST
QUARANTINE IN OVER 50 YEARS AND
A SUBSEQUENT TRAVEL BANDS.
THE MOB, THE MEDIA RACE TO CALL
HIM RACIST.
THEY SAID HE OVERREACTED,
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" INDICATED
DAYS LATER IT’S PERFECTLY SAFE
TO TRAVEL TO CHINA, I WONDER IF
ANYONE FOLLOWED THEIR HORRIFIC
ADVICE?
INQUIRING MINDS WANT TO KNOW,
MORE CONFUSED THAN EVER,
JOE BIDEN CALLED THE PRESIDENT
XENOPHOBIC, HYSTERICAL, ACCUSED
HIM OF FEARMONGERING.
WHAT WERE DEMOCRATS DOING ON
CAPITOL HILL?
THEY WERE CONSUMED BY THEIR
IMPEACHABLE STUNTS.
THEY WEREN’T FOCUSED ON THE
CORONAVIRUS, JUST CRITICIZING
THE TRAVEL BAN.
NANCY PELOSI WAS HANDING OUT
THOSE COMMEMORATIVE IMPEACHMENT
PENS AND TAKING SELFIES ON
FEBRUARY 4TH DURING THE
PRESIDENT’S STATE OF THE UNION
ADDRESS AS HE WAS TALKING ABOUT
THE CORONAVIRUS, SHE WAS BUSY
WITH ANOTHER POLITICAL STUNT AND
OFFICIALLY RIPPING UP THE
SPEECH, PREPLANNED TEMPER
TANTRUM FOR THE CAMERAS,
FEBRUARY 24TH -- THAT GENIUS
THAT LOVES ICE CREAM SHE WENT
DOWN TO THE CROWDED STREETS OF
CHINATOWN AND ENCOURAGED
EVERYONE TO VISIT.
IN MARCH, THE LEFT WAS TOTALLY
PREOCCUPIED WITH THE INSANE
POLITICAL NARRATIVE THAT THE
PRESIDENT WAS RACIST FOR CALLING
THE CORONAVIRUS THE CHINA
CORONAVIRUS EVEN THOUGH THE
VIRUS ORIGINATED IN WUHAN AND
CHINA, REMEMBER THIS.
>> WE ARE NOT BEHAVING WELL AS
WE TALK ABOUT THE CHINESE VIRUS,
THE WUHAN FLU AND ALL OF THESE
RACIST DESCRIPTIONS.
>> HOW DO YOU KEEP USING THIS?
>> THIS IS A VIRUS THAT CAME
FROM THE TERRITORY OF CHINA,
IT’S A BAT VIRUS, NOT A CHINA
VIRUS.
IT DOESN’T SPEAK CHINESE.
>> THE PRESIDENT SAYS THIS IS
NOT RACIST AT ALL ONE OF COURSE
IT’S NAKEDLY RACIST AND
OBVIOUSLY RACIST.
>> FOR THE PRESIDENT TO CALL IT
A CHINESE VIRUS OR A FOREIGN
VIRUS, THAT IS JUST NOT -- IT’S
DANGEROUS.
>> Sean: WHILE THE MOB IN THE
MEDIA SPEND MARCH USING THE
VIRUS IS A POLITICAL WEAPON,
WHICH THEY DID, OTHER TOP
DEMOCRATS WERE PLAYING DOWN THE
SEVERITY OF THE PANDEMIC.
BILL de BLASIO, HE WAS
ENCOURAGING NEW YORKERS TO GO
OUT ON THE TOWN AND CATCH A
PLAY.
THE GOVERNOR CLAIMED THE DISEASE
WOULDN’T BE AS BAD IN NEW YORK
AS OTHER COUNTRIES -- WRONG ON
BOTH PARTS.
NEW YORK IS AN INTERNATIONAL
CITY, NEW YORK CITY IS MORE
DENSELY POPULATED THAN ANY OTHER
PLACE IN AMERICA.
GEOGRAPHICALLY, THE SMALLEST
WITH THE HIGHEST CONCENTRATION
OF PEOPLE, FAR MORE RISK FOR A
TERRORIST ATTACK AND VIRAL
OUTBREAK THAN ANYONE ELSE IN THE
COUNTRY, YET THE CITY OF
NEW YORK WAS WOEFULLY UNPREPARED
UNPREPARED, SOMETIME AFTER 2016,
COMRADECOMRADE de BLASIO AUCTION
OFF THE 500 DESSERT VENTILATORS.
THE STOCKPILE OF PPE WAS
VIRTUALLY NONEXISTENT SO WHEN
THE VIRUS EXPLODED WHICH WAS
PREDICTABLE BECAUSE THEY HAD
MULTIPLE STUDIES INCLUDING THE
CITY OF NEW YORK, THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT CAME TO THE RESCUE
AND RIGHTFULLY SO.
IT WAS THE PRESIDENT TO ORDER
THE CONSTRUCTION OF NUMEROUS
EMERGENCY HOSPITALS AROUND
NEW YORK, HE STAFFED THEM FOR
THE MAYOR WITH FEDERAL
PERSONNEL.
HE SENT THE U.S. AND AS COMFORT,
HE ORDERED FEMA TO CONSTRUCT A
MASSIVE -- LARGEST IN THE
COUNTRY -- TEMPORARY HOSPITAL AT
JAVITS CENTER NT OFFERED BOTH
THE SHIP AND THE CENTER TO BE
CONVERTED TO ACCEPT COVID
PATIENTS, YOU HAVE TO CHANGE THE
VENTILATION AND EVERYTHING ELSE.
THE PRESIDENT ALSO SENT ALL THE
VENTILATORS AND MILLIONS OF
MEDICAL SUPPLIES AND MEDICINE
THAT de BLASIO NEVER HAD.
COMRADE de BLASIO, NOT
GRATEFUL.
SHAMEFULLY STANDING IN FRONT OF
A MICROPHONE ACCUSING THE
PRESIDENT OF LEAVING NEW YORKERS
TO DIE.
YOU CAN’T MAKE THIS UP, HE SAID
IT -- WATCH.
>> I REMEMBER FAMOUSLY IN THE
1970s WHEN ONE OF YOUR
PREDECESSORS GERALD FORD DIDN’T
CARE TO HELP NEW YORK CITY
DURING THE FISCAL CRISIS, THERE
WAS THAT FAMOUS DAILY NEWS COVER
THAT SAID FORWARD TO CITY "DROP
DEAD."
MR. TRUMP, MR. PRESIDENT, ARE
YOU GOING TO SAVE NEW YORK CITY
OR ARE YOU TELLING NEW YORK CITY
TO DROP DEAD TO?
>> Sean: COMRADE de BLASIO,
IF PRESIDENT TRUMP DIDN’T BAIL
YOUR SORRY UNPREPARED ASS OUT,
MANY MORE NEW YORKERS WOULD HAVE
DIED, MANY MORE WOULD HAVE BEEN
INFECTED, MANY MORE WOULD’VE
BEEN HOSPITALIZED THAT NOBODY
WOULD’VE HAD A VENTILATOR.
INSTEAD NEW YORK CITY THANKS TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP, YOU CAN
THANK YOU MR. MAYOR YOU CAN SEE
THANKFULLY A PRECIPITOUS DECLINE
IN HOSPITALIZATIONS, IF THE
PATIENTS, DEATH RATE, NOT FAST
ENOUGH BUT IT’S DECLINING.
COMRADE de BLASIO SHOULD BE
THANKING THE PRESIDENT BECAUSE
HE BUILT AND MANNED THE
HOSPITALS FOR YOU, HE SENT YOU
THE VENTILATORS YOU SOLD, HE
SENT YOU THE MEDICAL EQUIPMENT
YOU NEVER HAD KNOWING THE
THREATS WERE REAL FOR NEW YORK.
NOW YOU SHOULD BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR YOUR COMPLETE
INEPTITUDE, INCOMPETENCE, AND
FRANKLY, YOU’RE KIND OF
UNGRATEFUL TOO BECAUSE THE
AMERICAN TAXPAYERS, WE ARE
PAYING FOR ALL OF THAT.
THAT MEANS PEOPLE OUTSIDE OF
NEW YORK, YOU CAN THANK THEM TOO
TOO.
THIS BRINGS US TO SOMETHING
WE’VE NOTICED OVER THE PAST
SEVERAL WEEKS, WHILE THE
PRESIDENT FACES A HOSTILE
PRESS CORPS EVERY SINGLE SECOND
OF EVERY SINGLE DAY,
GOVERNOR CUOMO MET WITH THE
PRESIDENT IN NEW YORK, THE
GOVERNOR TO HIS CREDIT HAS
CONSISTENTLY PRAISED THE
PRESIDENT -- A FEW MINOR HICCUPS
HERE AND THERE BUT TO HIS
CREDIT, THE GOVERNOR HASLAM
THANKFUL.
THE GOVERNOR HAS WORKED WITH THE
PRESIDENT DAILY, WE HAVE NOTICED
THE LIBERAL MEDIA MOB IT DOES
TREAT HIM DIFFERENTLY, QUICK
EXAMPLE.
>> IS IT POSSIBLE TO BUILD A
POSITIVE SPIN ON THINGS GIVING
AMERICANS FALSE SENSE --
>> I DON’T THINK SO.
[REPORTER QUESTIONING]
>> WHENEVER HE’S NOT HERE, YOU
SAY WHERE IS HE AND YOU SAY IS
THERE A PROBLEM?
[REPORTER QUESTIONING]
>> HOW CONFIDENT AM I A FEDERAL
RESPONSIBILITY AND ACTION?
NOT CONFIDENT.
>> TODAY WE HIT THE GRIM
MILESTONE OF MORTY MORE THAN 40,
AMERICANS DYING OF THE
CORONAVIRUS, CAN YOU EXPLAIN WHY
YOU ARE READING CLIPS AND
SHOWING CLIPS OF PRAISE FOR YOU
AND YOUR ADMINISTRATION?
>> Sean: WHAT YOU JUST SAW, IS
NOT SHOCKING AND I DON’T BLAME
GOVERNOR CUOMO BUT I DO BLAME
THE MOB IN THE MEDIA.
THE SAME PEOPLE, FRANKLY HAVE
MANY HAVE BEEN ROOTING FOR
DONALD TRUMP TO FAIL, SINCE
DAY 1.
THE SAME MOB THAT SLANDERED AND
BESMIRCHED, ONE CONSPIRACY
THEORY HOAX AFTER ANOTHER, THEY
CAN’T ACKNOWLEDGE A SINGLE GOOD
THING THE PRESIDENT HAS DONE.
PEOPLE SHOULD ASK THE MOB IN THE
MEDIA, WAS THE PRESIDENT’S
TRAVEL BAN A GOOD THING?
DID THE PRESIDENT TO A GOOD JOB
BUILDING THE HOSPITALS FOR
NEW YORK, DID HE DO A GOOD JOB
OF GETTING THE VENTILATORS BUILT
AND ALL THE MEDICAL SUPPLIES
SENT TO THE ILL-PREPARED MAYOR
OF NEW YORK?
EVEN DURING A NATIONAL
EMERGENCY, THE MOB NEVER CHANGES
CHANGES.
THEY WILL POLITICIZE A VIRUS
BECAUSE THEY SO HATE
DONALD TRUMP.
MEANWHILE, MARCH 8TH, FAKE NEW
CNN, IT’S TRUMPS KATRINA.
IN THE MIDDLE OF TRUMP GETTING
THE SUPPLIES TOGETHER.
"WASHINGTON POST," THIS IS ERIC
PIMPLES PAPER -- CALLING AT
DONALD TRUMP’S CHERNOBYL.
WHEN PRESIDENT TRUMP EXTENDED
THE TRAVEL BAN TO EUROPE, THE
MOB SLAMMED HIM FOR INFECTING
INTERNATIONAL RELATIONS.
WHEN THE PRESIDENT DECLARED A
NATIONAL EMERGENCY, "TIME"
MAGAZINE CALLED IT A MISSION OF
FAILURE.
FAKE NEWS CNN CLAIMING TRUMPS
LACK OF IMAGINATION WAS COSTING
AMERICAN LIVES AND TREASURE.
"THE BOSTON GLOBE" NOT TO BE
OUTDONE BY ANYONE ELSE ACCUSING
THE PRESIDENT OF HAVING BLOOD ON
HIS HANDS.
THE PSYCHOS OVER AT MSDN SEE --
THEY HAD ONE OF THEIR PAID
COMMENTATORS SAYING TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WOULD DIE
BECAUSE OF TRUMPS CORONAVIRUS
INCOMPETENCE.
"NEW YORK TIMES," THE VERY SAME
PAPER ENCOURAGING AMERICANS TO
TRAVEL TO CHINA AFTER THE TRAVEL
BAN -- THEY WROTE THAT TRUMP
SHOULD HAVE SEEN THE VIRUS
COMING.
HE DID THE BAND THE TEN DAYS
AFTER THE FIRST CASE, YOU, SIX
DAYS LATER WERE TELLING PEOPLE
IT’S SAFE TO TRAVEL TO CHINA --
YIKES.
VERY ANGRY MSDNC -- A FORMER
McCAIN FOR PRESIDENT LIBERAL
STEVE SCHMIDT TOTALLY LOST HIS
MIND, WHAT IS HAPPENED TO YOU?
TAKE A LOOK.
>> MORE THAN 40,000 AMERICANS
ARE DEAD, THIS DIDN’T HAVE TO BE
SO.
IT’S SO BECAUSE OF THE
INEPTITUDE OF THE WHITE HOUSE
RESPONSE.
FOUR YEARS ON FROM A PROMISE OF
I’LL MAKE AMERICA GREAT AGAIN,
WE CAN SURVEY NOW THE WRECKAGE
AND THE MAGNITUDE OF THE
DISASTER IN THIS COUNTRY THAT
HAS BEEN WROUGHT BY THE TRUMP
PRESIDENCY.
THE INEPTITUDE OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT, SHOWS EVERYBODY
AROUND THE WORLD FROM ALLY TO
ADVERSARY WHAT A CLOWN SHOW
AMERICAN GOVERNANCE HAS BECOME.
>> IT’S SAD, PREDICTABLE, THIS
KIND OF RHETORIC IN THE MIDDLE
OF A NATIONAL EMERGENCY, IT HAS
CONSEQUENCES.
THE MOB AND THE MEDIA, THEIR
BREATHLESS EFFORT FROM DAY 1,
MAKE HIM INTO A VILLAIN.
A LIE, SMEAR, SLANDER, THEY DID
IT ALL.
TOTALLY LETTING THE WORLD’S
WORST BAD ACTOR GET OFF THE
HOOK.
THIS VIRUS STARTED IN WUHAN
CHINA, THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT
ATTEMPTED TO COVER IT UP, THEY
LIED TO THE WORLD.
THEY KILLED SCIENTISTS, MURDERED
DOCTORS AND SUPPRESSED DATE OF
THE WORLD NEEDED.
THEY SHUT DOWN ALL DOMESTIC
TRAVEL TO AND FROM WUHAN, BUT